if we look at the numbers of lives lost
in hospital you can see the rate at
which those numbers are increasing has
slowed today the number went up slightly
having said that 888 deaths were
recorded across the UK of course it is
unimaginable that we're talking about
these sorts of numbers and hundreds of
people losing their lives every day but
this does suggest that the curve is
continuing to flatten and it does fit in
with the longer-term trend that we're
seeing so if you look at the start of
this month the number of deaths were
doubling every three or so days now the
numbers of deaths are doubling every
eleven day so the rate has slowed but if
we continue at this slower rate we can
expect to pass twenty thousand deaths by
the end of next week and you'll remember
the government's chief scientific
adviser said it would be a good outcome
if we did it past twenty thousand deaths
it is looking likely that that will
happen now experts have long warned that
the key to tackling this virus is
testing and we have been looking at the
numbers of tests that are being done
across the country and you can see the
number of tests being done are rising
today twenty 1389 more tests have been
carried out but that is still only about
a fifth of that government target of a
hundred thousand tests a day by the end
of the month and if we look at where we
are compared to other countries you can
see we are below countries like South
Korea and Germany both of whom have been
seen to be very good at testing I've
seen relatively low numbers of deaths
but we're also below other European
countries like Italy and France it is
worth saying the way these figures are
collected is different so it does make
it difficult to make direct comparisons
but so far only not 0.5% of the
population here have been tested and if
testing is the key to getting through
this crisis this data does seem to
suggest that we are behind